ومن نوردا في غازي عنتاب معنى الان مدير
مكتب الجزيره عبد العظيم محمد عبد العظيم
بالطبع يعني لمن نجا الكهرباء والماء وكل
السبل المتاحه يعني هي المطلب ولكن ما زال
هناك اهالي يبحثون عن ربما فرصه للنجاه
لمن هم تحت الانقاض حدثنا عن التوقعات في
هذه المرحله
نعم ليلى الفرصه هنا في نورداغ في هذا
المكان الذي نتواجد فيه هذا المجمع السكني
الكبير مجموعه من العمارات السكنيه التي
انهارت على الارض هناك فرصه لوجود ناجين
فريق الانقاذ الذي في الصوره الخلفي هو
فريق انقاذ قطري من قوات لخوي القطريه
استطاع الوصول الى ناجين تحت الانقاظ
في اي لحظه نتوقع ان يتم اخراج ناجينا من
تحت الانقاذ هناك شخص كما اخبرني نقيب في
قوات لخويا القطريه قال انه باستخدام
اجهزه حراريه واجهزه الصوت قال استدلينا
على وجود كائن حي تحت الانقاذ تحدثنا معه
من خلال لم يستطع ان يتحدث من خلال مترجم
تركي بحسب ما اخبرني النقيب القطري قال
سالناه قلنا له اضرب اضرب على ثلاث مرات
على
بالحجر فيقول فضرب ثلاث مرات ثم قلنا اضرب
مرتين فضرب مرتين فتاكد لنا بوجود انسان
حي تحت هذه الانقاذ المشكله ان الحفر الان
في هذه النقطه هو حفر افقي باتجاه الاسفل
هذا البناء الذي خلفي لعل نعطيكم صوره هذا
البناء هو مكون من ست طوابق من واحد من
مجمع سكني هذه الست طوابق انهارت كلها على
الارض البحث الان عن هذا الناجي هو في
الطابق الارضي في اسفل ولذلك يتم الحفر
بشكل افقي لكن الاعمال كبيره بالوصول الى
هذا في اي لحظه الان نشاهد انا بجانبي
سياره الاسعاف وفريق الانقاذ المتواجد في
هذا المكان يستعد وجهزوا النقال الخاصه
بال
يستعدون في اي لحظه بحسب كما اخبروهم قوات
لخوي القطريه انهم سيصلون الى هذا الحي في
ايه لحظه هم كما قلت استمعوا الى اصوات
منه لم يستطيعون ان يحددوا طبيعه هذا هل
هو شخص امراه او رجل كبير او صغير في السن
لا يستطيعون التاكيد في هذه النقطه قوات
الاخوه القطريه استطاعت هذا اليوم اخراج
امراه وطفل وهذا اذا ما خرج وان شاء الله
يخرج الناجي سيكون الناجي الثالث
القوات الاخوه القطريه تعمل منذ الساعه
العاشره صباحا في هذه
المجمع السكني
النتيجه ستكلل بالنت بالنجاح اذا ما تم
اخراج هذا الشخص من تحت الانقاض وهناك
كم كبير من اهالي المنطقه يتواجدون خلف
الكاميرا وكلهم
باخراج حي بالنسبه لهم ستكون هناك معجزه
ان يخرج حي بعد اكثر من 110 ساعه تحت
الانقاذ هذه اخبار مفرحه ان لازال هناك
فرصه ان يكون هناك ناجين ليس في هذا
المكان وحده وانما حتى في بقيه المناطق
والكل يتعلق
باضعف الاعمال
باخراجنا ناجين هناك لا يزال المئات تحت
الانقاض يتم البحث عنهم في كل مكان هذه
المدينه التي نتواجد فيها مدينه نورداغ
القريبه التابعه لمدينه غازي عنتاب مدينه
مدمره بالكامل حجم الدمار مهول فيها
تتواجد فيها فرق انقاذ كبيره جدا انا
شاهدت اليوم على عكس الايام
السابقه فرق الانقاذ
تضاعفت اربع او خمس اضعاف عما كانت تعمل
عليه في الايام
الاربعه الماضيه وفي هناك فرق انقاذ تركيا
وفرق انقاذ دوليه هناك في نورداغ فرق
انقاذ قطريه وهنديه
يعملون في مختلف المناطق لمساعده فرق
الانقاذ
التركية كنا نتمنى ان نكون معك في اللحظه
التي يتم فيها استخراج باذن الله
الشخص الذي تم
ادراك او تم تاكيد انه على قيد الحياه من
خلال الضربات كما وصفت لنا عبد العظيم على
العموم سنظل نتابع معك في انتظار اخبار
جيده اذا من دور داغه في غازي عنتاب هذه
المدينه التي سمعنا عنها الكثير والتي لجا
اليها الكثير من السوريين خصوصا خلال
الازمه الاخيره شكرا جزيلا لك عبد العظيم